what's a fool podcast what's up fool was
a fool podcast coming at you right now
on the was so full podcast on the
octagons Comedy Network we got Rodrigo
Torres right here
how you doing pound for pain in at 310
pounds people nah dude I am 289 no we're
at 316 let's do that she had you at 309
come on that is not your real weight
whatever 292 lady no dude no you're at
300 oh that was fifteen pounds more than
you dawg how could that be
that's wrong even Johnny was saying that
he was like well he's 150 something that
had won at 170 well yeah let's do it
oh no that's true lady yeah I was
smaller a wee bit away I'm lighter in
Jupiter I'm lighter now did I come back
on the bread dude this is getting out of
control
yeah I remember when you I remember when
you found out you were over 300 pounds
it was when we were at the Griffith
Observatory years ago with his son yeah
it was like seven it was like eight or
nine years ago and before you went vegan
and it we were on the in that floor
where you can stand at the different
planets and you can see how much you
weigh on that planet and I was like wait
a minute that's three times the earth
and that says 915 pounds or whatever and
I was just thinking my mathematician
over here what they call GG that we are
Giggy over there add to that right in
Google yeah dude that [ __ ] was off you
are you sit down on a bench and with
that a machine that takes your blood
pressure yeah guessed your weight as you
sit down and you live in lakes yeah
another place to place your legs in the
back of this and a bar and a bar stand
still but it was off for about 10 15
pounds
I don't know man I don't think I weigh
280 man I'm [ __ ] fat by the way so
what's up Lisa lost 10 pounds
that's 15 pounds do you know I'm still
their pets about her change you lost a
little bit of weight before until why no
no was after okay I was well Oh Oh
before I yeah cuz uh in as of January I
was I was 170 pounds which is bigger
than when I was pregnant and then now
I'm 155 so man like drama going down
what happened
yeah what I hear some drama my little
yeah go to our old friend I'm Isaac
Flaco Martinez oh my god see he quit
that thing with that guy right what guy
Brian McDaniel what happened I don't
know they just cancelled all right
that's what he ended it yesterday that's
what I was reading he called me on
Friday night and I called him back he
still hasn't called me back
cuz I flick was there that one with
Paige if it wasn't for me Chingo Bling
when I do be doing stand-up comedy huh
huh no he said that was the one regret
he had it's in comedy was introducing
Chingo Bling to comedy okay so do a
comedy for a long time just would not
stand up this is the stuff that I know
about him and Chingo Bling in the other
dudes well two other guys that are on
the road with Chingo Bling now so that's
why I'm not saying names supposedly
those are the culprits that kicked him
out of the Chingo Bling Kingdom there
are Flaco bring those two losers in yes
I think so yeah Ching Oh bleep I want
some comida that were sober so what's
the drama that's unfolding on his page
but I started I know that I'm Flaco he
he he had done a bunch of our videos
with with Chingo Bling before they
attend of calm right right right but
they were all like when Chico bling was
doing a Canelo character yeah yeah the
other character I'll character base but
they don't know they they were they were
with another another group another
another production company like Travis
or something yeah and but she go bling
special who produced that you don't know
me - did yes they produced it they might
have only distributed it but I don't
they may have produced it but that was
the first special do more yeah I think
they did produce it they do want to do
more what they said in a meaningless
some specials come on my enemy hero I
saw a special on HBO than HBO Latino and
let me tell you man they were shot at at
the Potrero theater and in the valley
yeah yeah and I like those shows man but
I don't like when where now if you're
gonna have a show like that make sure
you get licensed for a good music
background a lot yeah it's almost like
elevator music in the crowd was too
pretty late there was pay to be there
yeah they have to dress up and get their
50 bucks
that's that those are the worst
audiences that's that one drink for
eight hours they're not there laughs
first of all bad do the by Rhode Island
crowd you really gonna work it hard bro
yeah yeah the UM when you did your
special your first special well the
second special - that's a just one of
your live shows but when you did your
first special they had audience
Wranglers and like building audiences
but we told your fans to go sign up for
you know as audience members so they
could see it for free and so it was full
of fans but there were a lot of people
at those other tapings or in the night
who had no idea who those people were
yeah people sure people showed up early
for that show about it what the Bobcat
they went to see the other guy and you
can tell like some people in the
audience were like paid and my first
message was like though this black dude
a mohawk Phillipe Esparza - happy it's a
guy from fishbone that's the worst you
know like when you gotta peel it like
applause you know the people were like
oh man let me tell you man well that
when I did the tape before Last Comic
Standing
big mistake why I bet at my mom and she
was there early bro I wish she was there
for 810 hours starving
because we couldn't go the bathroom
during the taping and like she caught a
t-shirt though she was all happy so you
get when they do a taping like that like
any tape in our Tonight Show any other
tape if you guys think of [ __ ] you can't
get up huh no not until they break and
you have to ask permission and all that
I did to get [ __ ] I quit yeah
remember we picked him up at Burbank but
you know what the Latino left for the
show was like that the audience yeah
they were they were paying them they
were paid actors they were yeah man I
didn't know that yeah they got paid 51st
water olive oh I believe all of them
when the devil with doing his prayer was
dead some people got some sleepy s
crowds why wait why you think are the
people stopped coming because they
didn't have the well I know that
okay local what we did it when it was
Gabriel and George Lopez I thought I see
bro yeah
massive see those were the shows but
then when you did it with a crowded no
dude it was in the back that's where
they had all the cameras are still we
were doing a lot of our smoking mirrors
are the audience totally that was local
comedy why why cousin its stand-up
comedy it was hot back there what could
they bring people in they were promoting
or what I don't have I have no idea dude
what was going on back lucky for lucky
they could have got out back then there
was a lot of comedians brother they
could have brought in an audience
oh hell yeah I call DJ couch he could
have brought it and he could have packed
that tough they put it they were out for
DJ couch Apsaras show either on that
probably took place as well yeah it was
towards the end of the season when Willy
30 hosted it now and the devil and it
was that it was called Comedy Jam hell
yeah it was Latino Comedy Jam and they
did Latino life a solo show the one that
Pablo hosted and then he bailed out on
him or whatever and then will he hosted
it after that that was with Jeff bought
this yeah that was right there and like
what those little Highland Park like
between Glendale those little those
Drew's for you bro there you go
yeah I was right there everybody had a
good time over there but taping the show
they go buy drugs on drew three
understand we're like when I'm comedians
you know they don't have their [ __ ]
together you know
like they don't have an ID through I was
driver license they can't travel
you can't catch a check they can't do
nothing they won't get paid in cash bank
account or they want to get paid that
like a taping most tapings like it was
low-budget you get the cash right there
right they give you a check right there
but if it's a real event they're gonna
mail you a check and SAG is gonna take
away the money but some people walk by
their owners dad that [ __ ] bad they want
their money right there that's the whole
thing of not being you know not able to
not having to not you never got the
little ropes with balancing your
checkbook and all that stuff I remember
this comedian man I don't want to say a
name man but he ain't around right now
but I'm he's not a big comedy but I
remember they give an application to
fill out and I feel our mind and then
like you know turn it in you know and I
knew that I owed money to to after
American Federation of TV and radio the
Union and I knew because when you do a
show for astra the first one no fees you
give you all the money that I heard a
dog is yours the second one they're
gonna take it but some comedians they
don't give it up they turn it a like ah
whatever right
so though this comedian was old he old
because he had another TV credit and
they told her right there and then and
they were gonna take his check this
first one having a fit got hostile I
can't believe I kept doing this workout
I'm [ __ ] kept a make it a scene
about the exposure I have to tell them
fool I'll put a put to the food to the
style and explain to him what to do you
got it man it's the way would it works
bro I mean no better not stronghold you
hear nobody a strong-arming you nobody's
punking you they think about no ghetto
[ __ ] fees it's the way it works bro this
is the way the world works the last one
you did he goes they kept him on you got
all the money right well this way you're
not and what happened when you brought
him back down to reality he was showing
me that he's alright but he was really a
task for somewhere else
oh [ __ ] ever taping he's doing famous
and he does another show pretty soon
he's gonna hold money again like the
third one even before you get booked for
the third one you have to sign the
taft-hartley waiver well actually sorry
the second one you have to sign
hartley waiver which says you're gonna
sign up for the Union the next time and
then you can't get booked on another sag
after thing after that after that second
time they won't hire you if you're not
active sag AFTRA
I thought it would be T man with my
first BT I said yeah I got paid out $150
or 60 bucks no got a hundred fifty it
was for though for a TV taping then they
moved up to 300 and then they moved up
to Alanna
Kathi's BT was doing other shows in our
lay at the casino the Normandy casino
and getting away with that pain that
much money but fine when people started
speaking up I'm gonna move to Atlanta so
again they don't have to paint the boots
were Lana but a lot of the good coverage
without doing the show so they raised
the price
the fee to 900 we're still non-union
those what you do but it's doing and
still what you would have normally got
paid with the Union
but now the residuals oh yeah do you get
the 900 and that's it and before that BT
would give you residuals hell no they
never give nobody residuals 150 $150 to
start to meetcha show to be aired over
and over and over
yeah you pay you're getting like like
Angela Johnson like she got paid 25
bucks for comedy time for that nailh
[ __ ] the beginnings like RBT was where
as three our TV is right now where they
could they have a lot of cash to pay
people but that's it that's it I don't
think I don't even know Spanish TV as
they repair anybody residuals yeah I
don't think they're most of them haven't
been Union they just joined sag AFTRA
like last year I think like last June I
think was awful
Timmy tee who's Timmy tee who knows by
Tommy T talk about pubes bro go floss
those peels off your hair off your teeth
one star fool we got shoutouts bro hell
yeah we do all right tiny
shoutouts this one's from Miss Minnie
10a
team in a great podcast I enjoy
listening to Filipe stories and all the
cool interesting guests you have on
please shout out to Marlene listening in
Costa Mesa
Jonathan listening at work at a a
concrete and Juan Pablo working at
SpaceX keep doing what you doing Felipe
this one is a shout out to a snow dog
rodrigo still has the best last in the
business nice to hear Lisa on the mic
more also keep up the good work
Arase Jo funk great podcast that reminds
me of sitting kicking back with my
cousin's on a Sunday afternoon keep it
up at Lhasa and east soil I really enjoy
this one one out of one listeners have
found this review helpful
I apologize now we have 19 haidle 85
hilarious show I really enjoyed
listening to your podcast been listening
since episode 1 cheapo episode Jay Marv
eeeh great show thanks for the laughs
I am a mailman your laughter gets me
through my route
thanks about those Duke 182 best podcast
out there being Chicano it's so
relatable but anybody growing up in the
70s and 80s can relate what's up fool
first review I ever wrote but he got a
little from Dicky's vanity are listen to
the entire enchilada casserole and
couldn't get enough of Lisa and you so I
started on this podcast and haven't
stopped listening
Rodrigo's laugh is hilarious y'all keep
me company during all the driving I do
for my job and on weekends when I Drive
out of town damn keep up the funny
stories and interviews much love from
you
vanity m-mister organic AMF thanks for
all the free laughs fool I hope to see
you live soon keep killing it bottle and
the last one but not least greasy monkey
3 100 love you guys I've been hooked on
this podcast that's what's up fool is my
daily ritual even if it's a repeat
episode shout out to the South Bay
Carson was so fool we talked about Timmy
tee bro that Timmy toe
is that single bro he from Fresno he
sings that song Timmy tee another guy
named Tommy Torres
just give me one more time no I listen
to it though it's called I met her one
time he came to my show and I'm in
Fresno he's like oh he has two hits like
people port of like I'm part of the 90s
you know the 90s movement of music you
know like Rocky buddy yeah yeah like 87
to 91 yeah that one song one listen to
the song
there you go master stranger one
freestyle see a freestyle singer who
sang time after time one more try Pete
my Papa go right here what's up my
brother
heard you say that last week Pete my
Papa go bro that's my homeboy
Rodney emails Robert he knows Rodney our
Fred the raw Native American program or
as they deliver the song that was
playing when I met now I do
[Applause]
[Music]
my hair lordy Lord singing Rosie vote
sovereignty I don't know the lyrics
where I will but you know this alright
yeah the answer you would hire you know
wasn't that great dog see Lola here
fifty pounds ago without you
in the five super form yeah karna bus
oh that's I don't know that's the
pronunciation Pima palpable did you tell
me that people different it's the older
language Otto has taken language of the
southern Arizona and northern Sonora
Mexico
Tohono o odham formally called a
palpable yeah I knew that
reclaimed there was food okay man
what an upcoming shows sold out Thunder
Valley Casino in Sacramento area I'll be
there with RIA Torres Johnny and
Marcella Cinco DeMayo Salt Lake City had
wiseguys they're brand new Jordan
landing location may 10 through 12
that's next week I'm coming in with
Rodrigo Torres Toby Higgs Johnny rocky
Nebraska Ignacio Colorado that's right
I'm going to nacho Colorado at Sky you'd
casino may 19 alright improv in Irvine
California up may 24 through 27 Regina
will be in Mexico bring me that toe
medicine bro
first shut up you'll be low
yeah be the Thursday show oh yeah I was
gonna give a startup or he'd be heating
up a la storia Rob what's up doc
a big done how you livin up I was
inviting him tonight but he look at the
Orange County huh
I don't know where that fool is that I
don't use from likes mdina or something
I know hit me up and I was gonna bite
off my head way up we wanted to guess so
like usually like somebody hits me up in
the morning and I think they're cool I
was invited to be a guest realtor shot
the last minute but then I thought about
it man I wanna be an [ __ ] you know
like invitees get the last minute he has
to leave somebody you know so bass blood
a lot of people would have showed up I
know I would've [ __ ] you you [ __ ] the
top part can would have caught me at a
Felipe I know man I hate to put this on
you man but if you could drive three
hours I am there now be in the carpool
lane dawg
imagine if we just caught somebody with
a they just caulk Amenia with with no
skills in a good car
speaking of skills shout out to skills
Hudson he moved up he's in Vegas right
now I think it's funny when Philippe
arresting the bureau song in German okay
here we go
oh do mr. Shawn come give me a hug if
you mean me DJ and come give me diner
huh all right you got it
oh you might as well just start learning
German dog I want to learn how to speak
French bro that's what I want to learn
come on I would trigger the wall if you
have a French accent and you smell like
[ __ ] it's still cool it's funny you just
say that cuz I was watching the first
episode of the second season frontier
and that French fool pops up dude when
that lady cuz she did they killed her
husband the fake husband and she gets
another one she wants to start slinging
those pelts
do that [ __ ] sound bad dude what's up
that did you see the part where I'm in
frontier where she somebody found out
that um that guy from Toronto is gay I
just said when they showed the head and
he almost fainted
all right right before that saw okay
yeah so what's up with that dude so with
you know [ __ ] anyone's man that dude
from Montreal he's a self-made man bro
like he started off poor he he earned
his way to the top that's later on
everyone
later on in the episode episode of
season 2 he says because every time man
nobody gave me nothing I didn't get no
half of my mom when I gave up that I
earned everything I got
then I laid throws in a little little
sexual thing I here bro bro wherever
you're treating that [ __ ] back there huh
well that French fool didn't want to
deal with her I'll do business with you
when your husband comes that brought a
back dead man it seemed like a woman of
a power had to marry a weak [ __ ]
to put him in as the face of the company
but you could run the company women were
property at that time though property
yeah you think they were property like a
slave or property of your mind stay home
yeah all that [ __ ] you mean you couldn't
do [ __ ] without him it's funny how like
because they often rely on the Bible -
there you go they were all that was
their hard Bible everybody what we're
talking about frontier it's a show on
Netflix and Lord bent it by the way
remember when Lord was that generous
with that new British fool showed up he
would I used to wear the first thing he
said are they following the Christian
values here oh yeah he said my [ __ ] you
don't know this country it's on your
world well see that's at the beginning
of the lost of control by the British
did a map people people like they know
they knew like the New London they knew
malt then you are whatever England but
the [ __ ] New World
it's like it's like territory they
didn't know like nobody unless you were
a hard core fool like like [ __ ] that
I'm the main guy or one of those
trappers you didn't go to the woods oh
hell no no nobody it's like it's
undisputed territory nobody will go
there huh and they're afraid of what
Indians there you go savages I'm gonna
take an arrow to the chest dog on arrow
to the mouth oh that one how about the
way the guy they'd put Lord Benton in
jail or took his power way how about the
way he died cuz promoter Jason Momoa was
out down there and they [ __ ] you know
they were helping him escape dude if I
could put that sword right through his
mouth dog Jason Momoa in it yeah badass
keep either have native have Irish guy
of course oh that's right you did tell
me that maybe I should watch it I don't
know there's a lot of
old British [ __ ] yeah that's cool
Reynolds for this venue but the man man
is crazy dog I would try to take you
guys out to touch it but watch you get
this guy's dead I want to see the entire
cast with everyone taking in France
French inspectors Clouseau french
inspector fake so so what's up Mario
Cruz that lady is very pretty yes she is
thank you Philippe should be on
something's burning with Burke Roger oh
that oh right here the cooking show now
blue white Thank You blue white nonsense
too much here for Phoenix Arizona big AZ
Ted Wilson orderly what's up boo AJ AJ
whoa what's up fool Oh a giant powerful
how everybody says so I'm watching you
just want to be his friend he didn't
want to be a friend boy yeah you know
what you are
I'll do the giant opens up your eyes on
stuff that we never thought about you
know like being that fat and being that
big like that fool said that our little
mixtures my size you know nothing for
big people like they never thought about
people being bigger than six foot six
so therefore said that he would be on a
plane by himself he took up two seats of
two seats with an extension bro
and he couldn't fit in a bathroom so
they ought to put a curtain and that
fool appeals [ __ ] and they were dumped
in the restroom we're talking 14 hour
flight here god damn and then and they
said his farts he's low farty bro like
I'm gonna call you [ __ ] I judge a junior
here here fart Manny we're gonna call
you obey yeah but and and and then I was
thinking to myself before we go I'm
going to ahead past the documentary
right also with a guy that made all
those obeyed keep giving a little cut
somebody blah shepard fairey a little
cut so using his using the image on the
premise that man ever went after him
famous
don't think combs his image he owns the
name probably now but I don't know about
he says that's what that would be his
estate
did you know like if he had an estate or
somebody that he's a big ranch to his
daughter okay cuz he jacked that and I
can't the misfits logo and he put his
head in there yeah yeah but what's up
what else is going on cuz they I heard a
lot of [ __ ] like beautiful mad dude and
that's what I heard they decide that you
never seen or thought you would have
seen yesterday that was he he was
friends right yeah at 15 he was sick six
already
and you know like he tried a growing
real big and he just kept his whole life
he kept getting bigger and bigger and
his organ stood the same no his organ
screws his always bro well and they were
telling him like at forty to slow it
down goes get the surgery but this is a
fucked-up part where that pool had a bad
back and he couldn't move no more and he
was talking to this McMahon that and
this big man is telling him about this
surgery could get but also we're having
this WrestleMania was thirty three
thousand people opportunity for
everybody it could be opportunity for
everybody that's that well we're holding
him spot for the first time yeah I
didn't know but I didn't know it then
but now kind of feel bad like I remember
the whole fight and I'll giant under the
giant never walked into the ring to that
fight
I remember now and he's a little crazy
doing it one position to the whole ring
if you want to fight I'll show you
though his back was killing him it's
ankle his ankle and he couldn't and then
uh Vince McMahon wrote down the whole
script of what he was the mass to be
slapping the hairdo this Hulk Hogan did
he designed the whole thing but he left
it open at the end I thought is McMahon
wrote oh he did yeah I was he said he
wrote everything and beginning to play
both no script right and right brother
Hulk Hogan on July 2
he looks he looked at him he was out
there the body slam me so then I'm whole
call him what yes
so he picked them up they don't worry
laying on the floor
I just changed the rest of the whole
fight leg drop
if we drop the leg he wins and then I'll
join gets back on a crane and knees with
Freddie belong with them I mean Bobby
the brain Heenan in a crane roll like a
dolly thing that's holding on to the
ropes
yeah the baddest appellee go through the
ropes bro like like that was a [ __ ]
bro bad ankle back back was there like a
[ __ ] soul that's not gonna get you
like making hope okay look good was
worth this price that's it you don't get
it Dawg he ain't part of that legacy
that money legacy but a lot a lot of the
baddest athletes always perform heard it
yeah you know I was thinking after he
was talking about all the big no you
know nothing big for big guys you know
now you can get stuff custom it was
harder back then but like things like I
was thinking about him holding just a
fork and a spoon a knife like say don't
you have to serve like you serving
spoons and forks you know to be
normal-sized because his hands were just
check can they they must be really like
eating with a toothpick
you know deadly I said everybody cooked
at home and of course he goes personal
assistant goes you knew I was coming
you let that live later you have to lift
it up cuz stuff can get stuck there like
you know and then you know saturate nura
and he said that up there was a part of
the locker room was only for wrestlers
and referees know assistants nobody else
because didn't want no one to see the
heel fighting with a girl getting
friends being friends so Tito Santana
was playing cards Tito Santana was play
like cards with other the giant and I'll
junkyard dog and another bad guy then
the guy walks in and then I'm I think
I'm Tito Santana look there's a giant
you know that guy and then a giant on
the run goes your toe for power here is
like a merger
yeah turning it in oh shout out to shout
out to
francisco the hizzouse ric flair with a
tattoo bro it will talk about it Peter
whoa I just want to say 22 foot 22 inch
foot 24 or 24 inch foot and then he had
a 8 inch wrist and this all this stuff
he said what do you think they're not
full like that there you want to see the
size of it this was a penis pinkie ring
yeah yeah dude you're gonna be a bigger
dude I love a man has don't mean Peter
says it all broke now cuz I have little
ass has some people I know but I know a
lot of powerful if at Hasbro and they
have a little penis bro dude my dad told
me that when he went into the you
drafted for shout out to James Sam step
bro you got a friend in me the only time
you see fools naked it was a bunch of
white food like big six-foot tall dudes
with little dicks it ease off I couldn't
believe it I thought they're gonna be
bigger and then his cousin was with them
cuz they're both gonna get rid of like
grannies [ __ ] up officer down
you guys been heavy guage watch roseanne
at all
I love that show but I you told me about
the first episode I watched the last two
I think it was it was like they didn't
skip a beat dude and you know obviously
tackling the issues of the day but in a
nice cool authentic way still looks the
house still kinda looks a little dusty
the mom's back in the mix she's over
there [ __ ] around with dudes dude
it's late Shelley Winters yeah senator
Byrd horses and a Burton she's in the
last dude she was awesome dude yeah and
um yeah the sister to Jackie everybody
dude Darlene I like that the show kept
it real keeping it real real and a lot
of people are trashing her because the
whole political stuff she's a bad
comedian dog and dude like that show
dude I haven't watched stuff on TV for a
while but dude that [ __ ] was awesome -
laughs - him and his son and his son had
a black daughter yeah the original rules
that he didn't want to kiss that black
girl yeah here gonna be with her
yeah I don't know where she's at is it
the same girl yeah but it's cool because
Rosa has like a cool-ass gram of the way
she was like oh it's really awesome that
line when you call that guy Gaylord the
Martin mole was getting married yeah
Martin Mull was getting married to his
longtime boyfriend on the show this is
when Roseanne worked in the diner for
Martin Mull the diner that was in the
middle of the mall and then Martin said
said maybe he was getting cold feet
before the wedding and he said uh maybe
I'm not gay I don't know like maybe this
isn't right for me and she said you
couldn't be gayer if your name was gay
gay Orson it's cool it's like going back
to your parents house after you moved
out yeah like the thing is that's what I
appreciate about I haven't watched this
these new episodes but that's what I
appreciated about Roseanne all the time
was that she was so real it was the
first person who was poor that's true
besides besides married with children
cool house yeah yeah after but but yeah
they were poor and they and and married
with children was more like a cartoon as
well in most of the state caliber one
who know the kid when I'm in suppose
that came out all the white people were
rich yeah
oh they were affluent like use copper
different strokes there were a money
struggle any shot no not always
disposable Ted but they were black yeah
but there was never a poor family
because I rose and when I saw Rosa and
that's when I saw these are people yeah
I even talked to her when she has that
knee pain whoever she's taking pills and
they're all like get off those pills off
when you guys Mary's the orthopedic
surgeon hilarious he's awesome dude
it was like dude yeah you know when
Whitney Cummings is one of the
showrunners it's to show others her and
then the guy Bruce Alfred the writer
forever yeah McDonald work Morgan might
be on the last couple of side
and Wanda Sykes yeah she had a lot to do
with it - she was in a lot of the pitch
meetings in the beginning - supposedly
Darlene brought all that stuff together
because she didn't want to be involved
in she don't want to argue a producer
the last time yeah so you know what
you're gonna argue for for the show
because Sara Gilbert was she had the
idea to bring it back because of all the
other reboots happening and then
Roseanne said ok if we do it I don't
want to be the one the fall guy I don't
want to be the one in charge I don't
want to be the one taking the heat for
everything I'll just be on it you know
so she's not in the writers room from
what I understand she's not you know
really speaking for the show necessarily
she's just the face of it oh no Rose
darling relax
that show is gonna tackle school
shooting because I'm Carmichael couldn't
maybe right but it dude Christopher
Lloyd does a guest spot - that the last
episode is so funny dog when we play
he's one of the dudes in Roseanne's
mom's getting with dude oh I'm not gonna
kill your mom dude that scene in there
dude is killer dog one of the funniest
things I've seen him dude in a long time
it was hilarious dude and it's an ABC
rice yeah and we're watching it through
the little Cody or whatever but I mean a
a week later but dude awesome
hilarious yeah man what's up foo did IH
another casserole podcast yesterday hell
yeah for 48 minutes I don't know if I
want to post it why I mentioned I felt
like I didn't have enough to say I have
to listen to it again I told one story
and then it was over and then I just
laid there like I was so tired because I
had a lot of accounting and stuff to do
this weekend I know man it was you were
you were like a little kid you were lie
to somebody and just kept that [ __ ]
light going we have to you don't to get
discovered funny
the Goldbergs bro I'll even tell you
about [ __ ] my pants like I used to
like [ __ ] my pants a lot and they would
be like
I know man I do not have like a little
[ __ ] cake and I've never told anybody
that was me [ __ ] my pants and my
family what the [ __ ] Mike just short of
everybody going around and spelling me
it's you but the [ __ ] I've never got
discovered that's a big ass line that
went on for like probably three years
that [ __ ] that long yeah do you know how
would you show your father but no whoa
dude I would go wipe good know did we go
on a little road trip or and I didn't go
to the restroom and then that [ __ ] all
happened I was like [ __ ] I gotta take a
[ __ ] so I'll try to hold it and then
just a little bit backing out yeah just
like just keep it together but then
people my dad's friend he's like [ __ ] no
they knew it was one of the kids but I
was gonna give myself up
somebody no idea dude I just wanted to
go away just crack the window a little
bit
and for a minute I would like I want to
I'll be I'll be like in the mentary
school afraid of five people like some
masking fool some black fools like for
some reason I'll be like not afraid but
do they have the confidence to fight
them but one time I farted in class and
then I'm the black foot said Oh homie
you farted and I told him [ __ ] you you
for the [ __ ] out loud and I
first took quiet bro and I pumped on
without even knowing but therefore I get
for it but in 40 minute I was more I was
more like more have more confidence to
protect my rep and then on fire as a non
foreigner then I was protecting myself
of being a [ __ ] like I'm so far they
are
you've already right oh [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] himself we're all loud
just killed him right there huh yeah man
but then I found out that food does [ __ ]
himself
what age do boys start to feel
comfortable
farting around other guys because you
guys do it a lot as adults I think for
love you know you don't well I'm just
saying like God are you if you say no I
mean like guys like say working together
or roommates together they're more
comfortable farting in front of each
other women don't really fart in front
of each other
by sauce two minutes oh the second or
third grade but I could do them from my
parent my dad like it like you were
comfortable around your friends
yeah
[Laughter]
however like standing next to dudes and
I'm behind them and like I would like
Danny [ __ ] smile I shared and I
put it to the papaya shared himself
alright I told you that one story that
one time about I walked in that makes
his restroom and Eagle Rock and that
Armenian dude was washing his underwear
so with you know I would've by myself
but I told you the story washing his
shoes he wears
oh don't worry go to the bathroom I'm
just over here to watch this guy was
water and was washing it no no he put
his pants back on but he's washing his
shiro that [ __ ] away bro okay but as a
little kid i packed and we hope in the
bathroom totally reminded me right now
when I was talking it's like I would go
and wash my underwears I would wash my
underwear just so my mom when she would
wash my clothes wouldn't know that I was
[ __ ] my underwears Wow I was I don't
know I don't know I did it's weird man
that was a lie man three year life Joey
Diaz and Theo von or some of Joey Diaz
his best guests with Joe Diaz Jody rich
you were sitting in class and everything
you [ __ ] no do you know yeah dude it
was [ __ ] embarrassing do this at the
foot of the nurse dog but do the [ __ ]
was coming out of his own pant it was
second grade someone's wrong with this
fool but the name Chicago but what
happened - I do yeah in January doodles
they sent us out to recess and everybody
gave him a high-five the next day I feel
sad for like a week but what for Vicky
we got recess dogs we could forget - 30
minutes
he took one for the team celebrated that
kid daddy I don't know what happened
however teacher will get in trouble
brought and leg of a kid peed and
they'll go to the bathroom I don't know
Isaac peed this was he was 5 in
kindergarten and that woman didn't let
him go to the bathroom and so I yelled
it I yelled at her after I yelled at her
after school when I went to pick up
Isaac from the after-school program he
had on different pants and I said
where'd you get these pants he said I
peed my pants
and I said you peed your pants what
happened and he told me this story I was
standing there I asked I asked mr.
Fernandez if I'd go to the bathroom and
she said no and I said she said no he
said yeah and then I went in my pants in
front of everybody
so I went off on this lady she was still
there and then I looked down and there
are all these little kids around me and
around us and I'm just like yelling at
her and calling her a piece of [ __ ] you
know yeah I said I said why didn't you
let him go well if I let him go
everybody else is gonna need to go and
and I said and I said I said she said I
think I'm a pretty good judge of when
people need to go I said obviously no
you know and she just thought he was
making it up and I said you know you
this is ridiculous you didn't let him go
to the bathroom he peed in front of
everybody he has on different pants I
don't know where his pants are and I was
so mad I said I really can't believe
you're my son's first school teacher
like this is really sad I feel sad for
all the other kids you've taught in the
past I think she she would like that
like kind of anti-white teacher he was
the only white kid in the class the only
one and then what's that mom she made
him do it
make him do a book report out of a
school trip she let him go field trip I
don't know she didn't let him go because
he was he was always antsy you know and
he wouldn't sit down I grew yeah why
kids yeah he would she has two kids
you'd think she'd know you know and
she's taught kids all these years but
she wouldn't let him he kept getting up
and and standing up and she didn't want
him to stand up so she didn't let him go
too
field trip to Echo Park right she looks
little but everybody had to write a
report on what they saw and everything
so he had the right one to make up a
memory he had to make up a story about
going to Echo Park watching you from the
balcony it was I I couldn't believe it
woman was horrible but she had tenure I
couldn't do anything oh I wrote a prince
the principal a letter but nothing
that's the enormous issue with the
school there [ __ ] that [ __ ] job that
[ __ ] [ __ ] miss Fernanda one time
during the World Cup she looked as cool
I would call the cops and then they're
waiting for you a thousand [ __ ] no
they have to like see they're like three
thousand times Mexican yeah
and they're one of the people that live
their whole lives as an immigrant but
now she's gonna tell us with an
immigrant we looked at you and then the
first year of school she was telling the
class the parents is so stupid he said
we all were standing there and it was
the first day of school and she goes I
want you to know I'm missing my
daughter's wedding to be here like
starting off the conversation like that
I want you to know how important each
school year is and then I'm starting to
think why it was it was like a joke your
wedding but I want you to go there [ __ ]
she said she said I'll be at the big
Pechanga later this weekend
I know what the casino but they were
marrying they were getting married
now if I were choosing my wedding date
Saturday right wouldn't you or even if
it's during the week wouldn't you invite
your mom or make it on a day when she
had isn't starting school yeah at night
and you know she's a schoolteacher
deliberately didn't want their mom he
didn't want her mom any oh and when when
Isaac's dad when Isaac's dad was
volunteering in class no no
Isaac's told his dad actually that they
were talking about New Year's
resolutions and she announced to the
kids he's her kindergarteners that she
was her resolution should explain what a
resolution is and she said that her
resolution was to not drink margaritas
so much
drunk telling us really we couldn't
believe she said that's my mother's name
that woman was awful Elysian Heights
Elementary there you go Jimmy garden
kindergarten math I'm professional yeah
she was ridiculous you know you were
with two arms substitute of school and
you met someone like that been there for
a long time tell you what to do other
tell you how to teach did one ever one
day [ __ ] yeah it's funny dude like you
need these assignments
oh no it's hilarious but see if you take
it like that you you know you're doing
yourself in trouble but I remember this
one teacher would come in there you got
to go do this you got to do that I'm all
cook it for a day and the next day I
just went to the principal is that what
I'm the principal you do what I say and
you already know what I said to do it's
on here on your on your daily
assignments don't listen to that lady
she's crazy we don't get her out because
of tenure he told Wow
straight up oh yeah a woman of tenure
like that woman but a man to a teacher
can be a [ __ ] won't get fired no you
have Melissa kill somebody or molest
somebody that's the only thing you could
could be a prick the kids your uh your
dude a lot of teachers have problems
with that you know they dude they're
just old dinosaurs they were all we're
PG huh that that way dude it's
ineffective it's anybody would ever be
promised a job for members they reach a
certain dude there's teachers that could
fall asleep in class I had I had okay we
had mr. Hendricks who wore a leisure
suit in the late eighties no he looked
like Jimi Hendrix and his name was
Hendrix Don King hair almost but this
guy would come in a leisure suit this
was social studies we only did
worksheets he'd pass out worksheets and
his desk with his hands down his pants
like this like Al Bundy like he would
sit there and just fall asleep the rest
of the class and then we just turn in
our papers and leave that was every day
it was like that that was his nap time I
couldn't get away with that crazy
it's horrible man Jarrod you have
teachers man that was that boring oh
yeah the teacher that never even spoke
to you or do you there's teachers or
or do the world mr. muñoz bro
well the my angry teacher he would say
like this today were reading were
writing nouns and adjectives he'll put
all the nouns and adjectives on one side
with the definition and we're gonna copy
all that and then really I put in a
sentence and turn it in that's it that's
it
he never dude ever and I was changed my
sentences to see this muhfucka reading
oh and you know they're really numb bro
but I will write [ __ ] like but the word
was decisive mr. mu nu a very undecisive
of whether to put up the same English
word last year and this week but it's
the same [ __ ] we did last week and I
never read it bro I still got it
that's awesome yeah the very same time
very bad it is not Shelley Winters
playing the mom on who is it the only
when I was died in 2006 I knew she died
I don't know welcome back Shelley
because she was great as well so shut up
to Omar Gonzalez blue white Lukas tea
time doctor 420 rats and faves suck a
[ __ ]
Alfred chana qua was food we measured
eatery yeah no you did stop I believe
okay everybody
Amy we're back Irvine improv California
May 24 through 27 Miami
May 31st at the Magic City casino I'm
headlining the ultimate Miami comedian
competition and closing it out with one
hour long set to check out more days to
go to Philippa WorldCom's that sort
because I'm adding new dates all the
time can i plug a date oversight it's a
June 12th at the Box in downtown
Riverside right inside the same building
the Fox Theater is it's gonna be v
bellows jokes at 8:00 p.m. that's June
12th well there's that June 12th is uh
Tuesday
but this June 11 people have been
wondering Monday yeah you and Vinny huh
well as cocky was cocky last name so
losito he's half Sicilian half Mexican
his mom's Mexican dad Cecilia
there was some Mexican yeah solar see so
let's see okay Mexican prison of course
he rises on you know it also pairs how
you look though bad oh yeah heroes later
Mexican but you look like a yellow that
you might go to the area
yeah but he looks like one of those
dudes it's always been locked up just
like you know that that prison pale or
that cell pal that's your part of all
people man they have that face like if
they see the Sun out of a window
yeah they don't even get brown they'll
just get sunburned right here shout-out
to Steven : June 12
that is birthday oh hell yeah happy
birthday dog what's up out of what
Canada was Ottawa and got out to with
red bands crew that's why they're squad
Ottawa a lot of people from death squad
bro they were they would give me shot I
was a they would tell me man you should
be under whatever show GRE right um
there's a there's an Ottawa what's the
card game death squad I don't what their
squad that I've been to the Edmonton to
the Montreal Toronto tremendous San
Antonio one to a San Antonio Florida
there they don't have the best squad
station no more ha I got the cash oh no
no that was kill Tony and they were told
what Brian Redman do this is but this
boy without everyone network within a
show yeah he had a podcast network with
a lot of podcasts going on but I guess
it just got too you know too much
working [ __ ] but they started they
started their squad started I'm jr. II
huh okay good he was there in the
beginning with him yeah he was likely
sad huh yeah did he was doing all the
technical stuff dude he helped Joey on
the beginning he put it was that Pat
read my pretty boy made himself forty
years huh yeah dude you gotta get in
somewhere bro
hell yeah he even told a story one time
you try to hit a louis c.k and she's
unarmed good i don't need any help thank
you buddy hey try bro I work at us i
text our louis c.k though day how's he
doing a man it's just checking in on
your man makes you sure everything's
cool hope i was good
there he goes hey amigo no he said hey
carnal or amigo or no I say every man no
how's everything there is everything
scoop wrong here with Paul Rodriguez and
I was it cool man since everybody
abandon him huh yeah a little Ghost
Rider here Bill Cosby bro what do you
think house arrest
yeah this time serve ha no dude 30 years
to the gill is that what this possible
it's possible because they haven't even
got him in front of the judge at or
whatnot yeah he's gonna appeal to I'm
right right and then it's in another
process he's gonna write it out dude but
if I was Bill Cosby I'm just saying you
put us to sleep right now I would just
not do that [ __ ] just take dude just
take your private jet dog and go to
Paris with Norman Polanski yeah the
Roman house or is right to the house
can't leave the house but like like any
like anyone in power anyone in power
that gets arrested at that or gets
accused as though it's embarrassing for
their ego ah of course you don't think
Lord betcha but he got slapped whoa
right now locked up he's fuming he's
asking the chick they used to call a war
the tavern lady oh yeah it's like being
a dick to everybody and then you don't
get your way and then [ __ ] dude
you're exposed I think about it and you
know the you know ruining of a legacy or
whatnot but he ruined it himself but
we'll just see what happens I mean is it
major I mean no Lisa mentioned that uh
but they didn't get it for rape
at least I mentioned that somebody
called our Bill Cosby told him something
and they were speaking they were
speaking it's like it's like you were
now are speaking and we're talking about
one of your brothers or your little your
son but just something old enough to
understand it we're talking about him
right yeah you're talking about him not
to him as well when he was being it
wasn't the sentencing but when he was
asking for bail his lawyer was asking
for bail and the other guy was saying no
he shouldn't have been a prosecutor
right amount and then he turned to him
and but basically they're talking about
him and I don't think Cosby's used to
being put in that place where people are
talking around him or about him and he's
not allowed
bro let's go bro yeah and he was
basically like you know he said he'd you
know it doesn't have a private jet or
whatever you [ __ ] like because they
were saying he has a private jet he's a
flight risk he doesn't have a private
jet you [ __ ] like you know he he used
that because he's not used to being
talked to and one thing they said to
though I mean obviously there's 5060
women saying that he did those things to
him but that they had got him on
circumstantial evidence right I mean
obviously it's gonna be 30 years later
whatever he did what he did to those
women but I don't know it's everybody
comparing him like all right all these
white guys had done the same thing but
every case is different it's frustrating
I mean it's frustrating to see like that
kid Brock get nothing you know and that
was a shitty judge who had a connection
to his father I mean he should have been
recused he should recuse himself but
those things go on all the time the
person in meek mill I mean can you
believe that he's dealing with what he's
dealing with
[ __ ] judge wanted him to she wanted to
like he wanted to hire him to help
somebody else with a song or something
like that right or ridiculous before
this case took place nothing will get
you disbarred you know get thrown out
crazy long sentence for weed position
right yeah and but it was ridiculous and
she's throwing he's trying to argue look
she has a personal issue with me I
didn't help her with this track she
wanted to come out yeah coming about
everybody's talking about it but he's
what's gonna happen yeah what's gonna
happen about that dude and that's just
like miss misconduct to the fullest dude
but that's every case is different dude
and do there's commissioners would you
act like judges they don't even have law
degrees in this country Texas that's out
like in the Commonwealth students
different like in Pennsylvania [ __ ] that
can ruin your life dude I didn't know
man I ever go to court and the judge
wearing one of those white wigs I'm done
magistrate yeah but that's all English
[ __ ] Old English it but uh out here at
least you have a chance in California I
would say some counties I guess it a
little different than others but yeah
man just this would be across the board
but Oh sir I'm thinking of Shelley
Winters was her grandmother back 22
prior Sopranos mom and she do you guys
think that um do you think Cosby the
strong enough man where this [ __ ]
doesn't is not gonna kill him like
something that happened like the Paterno
and [ __ ] I think yeah what I think
Cosby just gonna keep extending the
appeal as much as possible no no it's
too good right why does it represent she
has to represent till the end I think I
mean and that's what's crazy though if
they do get an appeal and he does like
it like cuz that's a good only gonna be
based now on mistakes so if they could
do something like that that's gonna be
like dude he may not get an appeal trial
like this appeal request but and then a
lot of people understand this country
there's a lot of DA's there's a lot of
judges that people donate to their
campaigns and later something happens
with those people they kind of you know
they don't charge them they don't they
don't file charges against them because
they have some kind of a relationship
dude I gave you a lot of chunk money for
you to be in that post and people don't
think it doesn't happen it doesn't work
it works but because when you can buzz
along yeah when you get busted by the
cops they file a police report
it's up to the DA to charge you with a
crime if the DA doesn't charge you they
just like you know you throw that away
they didn't charge him in the in the
Pennsylvania case and that's he and now
it's funny cuz Yale didn't they take
away a doctorate it's like it took a
conviction for you does it take a doctor
an honorable doctor who is honorary
degrees are ridiculous oh my god and
then you start calling himself doctor oh
yeah you think I had about Bertha
sleeping well at night
yeah I don't that funny me boy they keep
bringing them bring it up with that joke
been around forever five years before
that they were talking about it our
stories that people hadn't had it on a
phone accordingly
you know they had a lot of those people
probably didn't know the news story
because it had been joking that pretty
much you say that I'm hey man you black
people put you put your pants up man
stop talking all hippity-hoppity I'm
Bill Cosby had a sitcom a relativist
yeah but you rape women bill right
that's the truth so and but the thing is
they were talking they were talking
about Cosby being that the police the
culture police or whatever so you tell
Bill Cosby to have a Coke and a smile
and shut the [ __ ] up right like he's
been that way forever man yeah love you
too blue white but I'm Shaquille O'Neal
have an actual doctorate in criminology
he's not really a doctor of medicine
here's an actual doctorate in
criminology yeah he's gonna be a cop
like a doctorate yeah a criminology I
think and us to be an officer he's gonna
go undercover I don't know I don't think
he sat through all that I mean I don't
think he went past the be a butcher I
roll up him in a live but he will a
premier lives what's the name of mondo
text me yesterday with a picture of
tacos from Cinco puntos nopales in like
la Kamali
you don't like no Paula Zahn okay create
your menu for you Transpo's talk what
Cinco Cinco puntos tacos and that's
first I think they release up what oh my
god and I had to [ __ ] burrito at 3
bites and it burned the [ __ ] at me but I
was so good alrighty I had but one was a
lot of beans and their red sauce oh my
it was read me yada-yada
yeah basically kind of like a story yeah
man but um I like those taco burrito was
so good because I'm I don't know man I
just first you know like so burrito they
put a lot rise me if you're sorry
that's no me go ahead known as no highly
any rise which just beans and meat a
little bit of cheese drizzled and I
couldn't drank it bro would those but me
at least I went to another place that
had the similar but we don't like them
and they were real good jockeys Silver
Lake in Silver Lake
yeah you cos you got yeah that's all
that's you know too many onions those
feelers know across the street from I've
only been that one across the street
from Ralph's yeah what I like about cut
them up that way no hard but they're
fresh so there are nice and soft
yeah like you let you go was good bro
yeah yeah and that's are they have
cochinita pibil I don't have yuca yeah
you know you you got to write about the
day they do have the cheeto number we
know the soft kind heart is delicious
dude and forty men like I would think
I'm now back then I was now I think it's
gross but I remember back then I even
thought it was gross - I bit it of
course dude and because I thought
because I never liked the the you know
like mushy me ass but that one I felt
like you were right it was regular tea
chocolate they smashed and then still
people don't smash it first so we were
cookin she's done road with the team it
could all soft yeah and it's not
supposed to be there survival broad did
it at that for me man it was Chicago
brother with a chef and he made me a
torta bro with each other on but he
didn't do it like you did it he cooked
it with a long pieces yeah it was
awesome when they cut it up and they put
the sauce for get up yeah if you have a
good char on man and a good cousin man
or lady dude you can't beat it
yes the shack did earn it with completed
54 credits mostly through online courses
and video conference for years but he
got a 3.8 grade point average and he did
it it's not an honorary degree that's
amore
it's a real one I don't know what that
doctoral project was that he had
something like to see that damn I just
ate you guys are making me hungry again
we've been breaking foods diets huh hey
dude
well the last thing you ate that was
good you could have Mexico horrible
tacos
yeah yeah um the last thing I was good
with just a steak that I made on was
that Friday bomb but the good good last
time I ate was that French restaurant
right there so we'll see like Frankie
for bloody bloody no you're a solo with
these fools dog killing me over here
master stranger one buddy who he pay to
take those classes a lot of those
Sherlock Holmes
[Laughter]
wasn't he on a horse when he was with
Miami yeah he was like like a consultant
or something or he was kind of deputized
or something like that he was a
volunteer okay yeah I ain't gonna see
him hiding behind a car come on do your
business put yeah is that [ __ ] what's up
dog
Oh wearing his jersey and [ __ ] I know
it's stupid two men went stupid to go
with the cop oh my even's to call
impressions right be the Steven Seagal
seriously Gulf Shore suck so bad that
they'll be tired like one time there was
a black kid walking and that spider
senses like spy division by division
we're gonna pull over he would have
pulled him over and that kid had a [ __ ]
your 12-gauge shotgun in his [ __ ]
pants yeah and then some kid hit I guess
by a car thought away he spoke Asian
Cajun like he goes wait baby got hit he
said he actually said that when it baby
got here he touch that blender boo boo
boo got here all right
I watched that show was because he was
on my chat they doing that putting up a
character that was a good curve yes dude
and then he did that show I was like
what the [ __ ] he [ __ ] up dude but I
watched like ten episodes I said he said
can't even get out
oh man well III I'm surprised they
haven't called off Steven Seagal for
sexual harassment
well supposedly there's a bunch of cases
but nothing sticking but I could I read
I'm I went to this thing eight horrible
things you didn't know about Steven took
all the compartment and one of them was
um that was on that girl that's married
to Marky Mark's brother Jenny McCarthy
bro had a story she said that she was
sitting in and without Stevens to go I
don't know if he was in a dressing room
but he was telling her Stevens to go
with Talan Jenny McCarthy about how long
into this Asia and wisdom and Asian
there's the word a kimono and then Jenny
goes blah blah blah blah so we could we
got queried now like what about the coup
yeah let's get to work could we run
lines and then he goes up he asked her
arm could you take off your her clothes
bro cuz the the girl is seen you know
blah blah blah I want to see how pretty
you are
and she just left I could see that we
get away we should let that huh well the
thing is Philippe India I was used to
get away with it eight that bro what is
it that there's chicks there wanna dude
yeah for everybody I'm not trying to
justify sexual assault or anything but
it does happen do it dude it does how do
I've heard chicks dog didn't even like
all the focus off stage and kills and
this is going back ten years did I want
to be with that guy right there gold you
know like say that it happened yeah come
on it was that wire told me what today
we're working a movie and he said the
girl brush I for a better role I dig
what the [ __ ] wrong with that yeah
I've heard that before
since women like that that that thing
people like like Harvey all these guys
every Weinstein Stevens ago they think
we're it's okay to do it it's there are
Horrors so they go on yeah and now we
put you to get you with all these
[ __ ] are [ __ ] [ __ ] yes or lines
yeah some lady that's actually not
really in it for the
have skills manners gonna get in there
blown her way to the top and it's funny
though you bringing up homeboy Weinstein
because that supposedly happened with
his case in New York why he wasn't
charged criminally because supposedly he
donated money to that do there was a the
head of that Manhattan office right now
this you know didn't charge him not
crazy so that and that was you know
donating back when this fool here
killing me it wasn't me about Lucas two
types deviance the goals is the great
bad Steven Seagal's remember bro at that
when he has a police show at the end of
the show his band will play bro they
pray that shitty ass blues music bro
that's like dude what is it New Orleans
blues irobot New Orleans blues I don't
know no [ __ ] doubt love their fuses
the Papa that's Apple jazz yes what is
it called
you're talking about you're talking
about Calypso know there's zydeco zydeco
but that stuff is Cajun right it's well
there's Dinoco and that's a pollutant I
don't know might know how for know I'm
New Orlean Blues bro ain't down for no
Kansas City Blues ain't got a [ __ ] ACOG
oh they got a beat Chicago Jazz Steven
Seagal's is a finish country band from
Finland playing bluegrass versions of
well-known hard rock and metal songs you
see you see mr. gold shoutout to
francisco the hair shows don't be late
to work pool this was a jazz fusion
fusion the worst bro is of that jazz
station bro cool jazz or smooth jazz I
know you're not
you know hilarious who was a big fan of
that station Jerry no mom used to
playing as far as a little man you know
what kill me without foolish way Dennis
Soto or whatever bandit was there for
butter the bongos to play with it a
little bit play with him laughter no bro
they want you to leave I thought he
could do everything man it's just like
come on everything what brush his teeth
bro
mando says things I don't think he's
writing in the throat
our French I knew Fredo there is great
jazz music out they should listen to dr.
Lonnie Smith Herbie Hancock Herbie
Hancock good back in the day Chick Corea
back in the day
Miles Davis of course all the eras of
Miles Davis Miles Davis on the corner
and a really good album not a good cats
out there but no the wave plays smooth
jazz smooth Kenny G style jazz also that
woman up Adam who that woman now what's
her name she hurt her husband is a jazz
player too no Diana Krall and oh and her
husband plays jazz - he plays saxophone
he plays and she plays piano a harp I
don't know oh you're thinking Alice
Coltrane yeah yeah now let's call trains
awesome great yeah man you want you know
Jack go check out Alice Coltrane yeah
what's so cool from a child Sam Vieira
master stranger four big Vario gb
master strangers from the Lupus bars are
worth so give me some Toby bro yeah was
good Thank You felicity everybody
so how was that deep breathe out yet oh
man it was wonderful I'm gonna introduce
this girl to Mikey
and go to hop whoo-whoo-whoo shut up -
ha whoo ah lah Herbert Kang will be
great porn name
Herbie Hancock that's funny man I have a
cousin in Waterloo pay expires there
somewhere
Toby Roderigo Roderigo is the Mexican
Cleveland is Cleveland is Pittsburgh the
black one yes bro but before we go about
what happen she wolf do ya all right go
for it oh I thought it was I thought I
didn't see the whole thing but I
remember when was this Myers hosted it
he [ __ ] up trouble bro oh yeah
he made up angry that's the year the
true by humans will know an end I'm
sorry Obama shrug got roasted so hard at
that White House whatever it
correspondent dinner that he could
attend him not coming back because he
got roasted harsher and it's what I
think it's what solidified his Thank You
Obama yeah no Baba straight up stand up
well you will you know what your quit
your show keeps me up you know you're
gonna give the job to Gary Busey and I'm
something you'll never be and that's
President and that's when that but I
would have thought about that girl cuz
you know usually sometimes you know
they'll get her like kind of like a
right-leaning comedian to do the
Republican one left you know one thing I
didn't just see the clip she did I did
the one where she was trashing the left
dude she was trashing
and she trashed Congress the media and
to me that's what's up that's what
that's the best one she did what she
said you guys right here should be
thanking Trump he should be you should
be honoring him he made all you guys
here he helped you guys sell books you
know popular he helped you guys get
ratings he's studying papers if anything
you guys shall owe him
because he has yeah he doesn't have any
and then she went into the pain now good
for hilarious everybody all she would
[ __ ] Dennis Miller bro Janice Lillard
and everybody watching this show if you
like this podcast this Star Trek [ __ ]
Dennis Miller you win for that you were
funny read what his wife said about bio
well her by it well we night when they
got a divorce wives were she said was
married to a man with a small penis who
thought he could be funny without
writers she was she was like kind of
Rosie well no that's why she isn't doing
it nobody that with you 24/7 Koch knows
how to hurt your way oh yeah a man with
no teeth and Betty and Bob Rae and
bachelor that a man with with a very
small penis who thought he could be
funny without writers Dennis Miller dude
it's hilarious dude that's what never
made me laugh but he only made me not
one time and that was our [ __ ] out
Joe Dirt it's always been confirmed
McDonald's by the [ __ ] [ __ ] and can we
say did we say yeah we did talk about
Mike Tyson mysteries is the best show on
TV right now
yeah well animated show he's a little
pigeon but he's not even the best part
of it Mike Tyson is just [ __ ] awesome
I don't care he's fun with that [ __ ] on
he is owning the comedy that is Mike
Tyson the best water with them he shows
up on a now bro I mean what the [ __ ] you
doing here [ __ ] but then like it
takes it to the end sticker you dropping
me as a client [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and
they go into a room and they ring the
bells for - welcome back pain and he
[ __ ] sucks to share that goes
I'm sorry bad I hear a bell bag let's do
it back out that's cool were so food
taking everyone for listening to the
podcast hello will be done for years you
may know right now about an hour
what's it yeah time flew but you don't
know 30 minutes or so full podcast take
everybody for showing up and listen and
watch news live
that's right blue white Norma is 100
David booty ah go Omar Gonzalez
the wife's Portuguese nonsense master
stranger what the white Portuguese Jay
Simpson take it very much bro Edie madam
and get oh shut up to Jimmy or yang
killing are killing it on the rich ass
Asians yeah he went over to China brew a
stop and all the new he didn't wanted to
make Chinese persons of all these out he
did Chinese version of Facebook and all
that [ __ ] over there bro yeah oh yeah
I'm it's not watching that show one more
shout out to Brendan Meehan he's
listening in Ireland says the podcast
gets him through the 13 night our night
shifts you go brother go follow him on
instagram at Brendan Behan dots 35 and
maybe you can have a friend in Ireland
and awkward dude aka hey underscore John
underscore boy on Twitter what's up fool
thank you Lisa
Rodrigo we'll see you guys next week
we're gonna have a good ass guest one
love for your show until next time man
we love you guys we started off with 32
lists viewers we got 69 was keeping at
that thank you very much man
enjoy yourselves god bless you Ping's I
still have a lake up Mahalo Mahalo